IT IS TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
THIS IS VERY BIG NEWS GIRL MEETS
WORLD NEVER AWAITED SEQUEL
TO BOY MEETS WORLD PREMIERS
TOMORROW NIGHT BUT IT'S
EXCITING.
A NEW GENERATION GROW UP
WONDERING WHY ANYBODY WOULD
NAME THEIR DAUGHTER TOPANGA.
I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH THIS.
I TOTALLY FORGOT THAT AT ONE
TIME MAYBE I MADE AN
APPEARANCE ON BOY MEETS
WORLD AND I HAD FORGOTTEN
UNTIL YOUTUBE WAS LIKE MAY
CHRIS HARDWICK REMEMBER THIS
WELL THAT'S THE END OF THE SHOW.
--
>> YOU LOOK LIKE HANNAH
HART.
>> I KNOW, I'M A YOUNG
HANNAH HART IN THIS PICTURE,
I LOOK LIKE A YOUNG HANNAH HART.
(APPLAUSE)
IN HONOR OF GIRL MEETS WORLD
THE HASHTAG IS TV SHOW
SEQUELLS, EXAMPLES WOULD BE
THE GOLDEN GIRLS ESTATE SALE OR
SEX AND NORTH-- WELL THEY
WERE ALL VERY OLD TO BEGIN
WITH.
OR SEX AND NORTHERN NEW
JERSEY.
OR HOW I WENT OUT FOR
CIGARETTES AND LEFT YOUR MOTHER
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND
GO. GRACE HELBIG.
>> ADOPTED BLACK.
>> POINTS. HARLEY.
>> BILL NYE THE GUY WHO
FINALLY ACCEPTED JESUS.
>> POINTS. I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
SEQUEL WILL EVER HAPPEN.
>> DR. HOW.
>> YES, POINTS.
>> THREE MEN.
>> HANNAH.
>> THERE WENT HONEY BOOBOO.
(LAUGHTER)
OH PLEASE OH PLEASE OH PLEASE.
>> POINTS. HARLEY.
>> TO PAROLE A PREDATOR.
>>HOW DID YOU FIND ME! YOU'RE ON
PAROLE. POINTS.
HANNAH.
>> THE BIG BANG FACT.
>> SOME DAY, POINTS. GRACE.
>> THE VAMPIRE TUMBLRS.